and Katy brought you a present under
since when did Christy ever get into
that I'm gonna record everything game
you know if several choices when it
comes to the person behind the camera
and Christy ain't it also not sure if
I'm actually watching the movie or
accidentally hacked some random person's
iCloud account by Katie previously on
Paranormal Activity this is the most
frightening thing I've seen so far
any sane mother should know you don't
put a baby to sleep by slinging them
around the room two questions is that a
weird pattern on her shirt because it
looks nothing like blood spatter I
thought it was the map of the u.s.
printed on her shirt at first
and as the man on the couch supposed to
be dead or did the remote just get lost
in the seat cushions Katie then walked
outside for miles with a baby and blood
on her shirt without anyone seeing these
people are just constantly filming
wouldn't someone ask them to stop just
put your phone down and enjoy Halloween
with your kid he's probably gonna get
abducted looks like the houses in Rob
Zombie's Halloween remake this house is
decorated with all the Halloween
jump-scare crew yeah just record
everything in my house that's fine I
still know absolutely nothing about
these people at least with the last
group we got a few names dad getting
after his daughter because she is
wearing a skimpy outfit cliche what what
exactly b-series known for its lolz and
excitement subjects me to kid soccer
main character kids sucks at soccer this
is like the Blair Witch Project meets
Full House movie series known for its
lows and excitement subjects me to kid
golf movie series blah blah blah video
game table tennis season tell me why is
this asshole recording stuff does he
have a premonition about future activity
that will be useful in the first true
sequel to the first movie seeing these
teenagers about to make out I now think
I shouldn't be watching this for legal
reasons trespassing mom is single and
apparently she she's really busy she
she's not really so starts the dumbest
plot in the history of these movies the
mom is Katie and I guess she's sending
out a kid spy to do future which diamond
dirty work all the while hoping that
this dumb family takes him in when she
goes to the hospital later but yeah this
plan somehow works Skype her normal
activity do you even know his mom though
I think it's really nice but you don't
even we didn't even know that character
in the movie openly questions how stupid
it is that the creepy kid gets to stay
here
where are you going seriously this
static shot happens for 33 seconds
before some asshole kid runs in the
background for a movie series that
constantly jump-cuts it sure doesn't
know how long to keep people waiting
during these kinds of shots also it's
literally a bunch of nothing just for a
cheap jump scare of her jumping back to
bed they probably just got to the end of
editing this movie and realized it was
only 30 minutes but instead of trying to
advance the plot they just added large
sections of still camera pointed at a
wall in total invasion of privacy ID
that is the sound of a 16 year old girl
who doesn't care that she's been filmed
without her knowledge and so he woke up
before she woke up I'm guessing or else
this wouldn't have been a surprise I'm
kind of doubting it but whatever also
when we find out later this kid is just
a demon recruitment tool for Wyatt how
exactly does it figure into the plant I
feel like a little boy who has just been
through a traumatic experience wanting
to be close to someone it's more
excusable than a guy secretly filming an
underage girl on their video chats we
are almost 20 minutes into the movie and
someone finally calls her out I'm
constantly recording everything
the first ghostly looking figure that we
see is an Xbox Kinect character the
scary moment brought to you by the Xbox
and Windows frightening people into
thinking they lost all their data since
1995 Connect dance party it's Robbie
doing
Robbie is weird if you didn't know that
you periodically stopped listening every
30 seconds it took the power of Kinect
to solve the mystery of recording the
somewhat image of Toby the demon
literally two minutes of what can best
be described as a terrible real estate
video this is night one I feel like I
could have just hopped right in here had
the same if not better viewing
experience they are doing exactly what
they should be doing at 3:00 in the
morning there's no conceivable reason
for you to be up right now of course a
minute ago Alex was walking through the
house with a laptop and the image was
perfect in low-light now she's using a
camera and we get the good old Paris
Hilton chic color scheme I think the
world's horror screenwriters were
trapped in a high-stakes game of duck
duck goose as a kid so now they put
people running by horror cliches in
every single movie they can't dafuq is
that that was just as abnormal as the
other Kinect experience from earlier
this one was just jumpy er yet everyone
is so much more alarmed by this
experience also we have no score of any
kind so far on the first ghostly
movement introduces this boom sound was
that added afterwards by whoever's
compiling this footage Paris oh it must
be some intriguing backstory where the
witches cast a spell on all the adults
in the house so they don't believe no
matter what the evidence well someone's
seen Paranormal Activity the plan is to
put all sorts of laptops all over the
house and hope that nobody thinks that's
weird at all most of the family in this
movie must already be dead
paranormals second hand will help screen
we find out later that she's gonna be
watching these videos with her buddy Ben
later and she's basically making a peep
video for him right now
right into 93 I guess someone had the
wherewithal to do some editing these
kids think they can get away with this
probably because they saw in the last
movie and figured these laptops are
capturing footage all day they really do
have magical devices with infinite
harddrive space I can see that this
family needs another role spelling the
contraction you're as you're when you
mean to say you are that goes for you
too internet movie steals the stairway
scene from The Changeling of course now
that Alex knows she's in a horror movie
she guests yells someone's name all the
way across the house any time she hears
the noise and I'm sure the hello is
coming soon too
yep this ghost kid is more messy than he
is scary so not footage somewhere of
someone placing all these toys in the
ground are they that good at avoiding
the camera when that happens her
reaction is let's follow the path of
toys and open the door where they lead
and not all right it's time to burn the
house down
demon grew in much bigger Whang between
1988 and 2011 both chandelier placed in
random section of the house for scaring
purposes is bull also they can't just
Jack scary plot points from venom the
Opera the situation has got serious
enough to stop filming imagine trying to
have a very important conversation with
someone while actively filming them
there's no way they would take you
seriously I think something might be
wrong with rowdy and he brought a ghost
into my house so I'm not only entitled
to open this gate at 2:00 a.m. but I
have no fear whatsoever movie steals the
big wheel scene from the shining OH
a chair also this prankster demon and
his pranking at this point even the
demon is clearly bored of his own antics
you know what I realize now I have no
idea if this is the creepy kid or the
other creepy kid Robbie takes why I had
to see the demon somewhere but it is
curiously doing prankster behind them
with no one around to witness it there's
a shadow to face what who who does not
like hey how does this little dick know
that Ben will be in strangle shot of the
demon when all this goes down the past
two movies think that a child talking to
a demon off screen is some sort of
suspense builder how long can they go
with this sort of horror Tantra
demon lawyer it's convenient that the
first result on Google provided them
with all the information they need it
hello boob and this Toby dude really
hates kitchens by the ladder every time
he walks into one its gravitational pull
kicks it so and based on the hauntings
I've seen so far I'm not entirely sure
this ghost isn't a cat is it normal for
this girl to be up between 2:00 and 3:00
in the morning
I'm started I think then insomnia is the
real problem here car didn't make any
sound until it was time to jump scared
out of you
also is there any need to look through
the viewfinder while you're crossing the
street yes
that's racist also I don't think that's
what Toyota had in mind when they paid
for that product placement super secret
which Kevin keeps their door cracked so
that any Scooby Doo who can walk into
this place Alex hears screams of fright
and pain so of course she finds two
little boys just having fun in an
abandoned house will be series with tons
of unanswered questions raises more
questions movie steals a scene from the
ring wouldn't be the first time either
ah dark figure image projected on a
surface by an opaque object blocking
light hey remember the knife well it's
bad so there how did she know that
you're adopted though just man okay god
damn it this is the bullshit thing I
have ever run across before and I've
seen four Transformers movies in an
episode of Richard Diaries
this movie is saying that Wyatt is
hunter Katie's nephew she stole in the
second movie that opens up a line of
inquiry a mile long mostly the question
I want answered is once demon possessed
Katie and a lethal witch coven took
possession of the kid why was he put up
for adoption this twist I am physically
hurt for this stupidity Paranormal
Activity movie finally shows us that
demons can open doors watching this
movie at two times speed is a slightly
improved experience over watching it at
normal speed that's not as much as sin
as it is a helpful tip which was you're
sure we planned on producing but had to
cancel because cinema tips was already
taken by an adult entertainment
committee demon decides to show itself
more clearly this time because it's
close to the end of the movie also if
he's talking to the demon right now then
who is this behind him kid who is
important to the demons witches and
whoever the antagonist is in these
movies is dragged down into the water
for no good reason at all number one
rule of parenting
don't leave your kid alone in the tub
because a ghost cat might pull them
under the water and drown them which is
weird because regular cats are afraid of
water but not ghosts cats
I can't the demon simply may quiet walk
over to the witch house and possess him
in private what's with all the ceremony
of the water is this supposed to be some
sort of backwards baptism I'm not amused
Skippy
she conveniently takes sleeping pills on
the night that ghost cat decided the kid
needed to creep around why did
need to do anything with this family
can't they just kidnap Wyatt and run
away are they afraid of legal
ramifications also hey thanks for
keeping our precious kids safe for
several years now suffer the
consequences
there is no Dana only Zuul also what
what's the point of that
they just later back down and left but
also while this ghost has been in their
house he has knocked over a few things
and looked at a teenage girl out of her
bed making him more slight annoyance
than a real problem by the way it wasn't
the point of all these cameras so that
she could see the weird stuff going on
has she seen the clip of her floating in
the air last night the other weird put
that ghostly figure behind Wyatt are
these cameras being used in vain now now
is this can someone punch it so I don't
have to they should be why are her
parents not home at 1:00 in the morning
the only logical explanation is if their
marriage counselor is a vampire because
they definitely aren't out on the town
what this movie needs is some good
spinning and she is still holding on to
that laptop carbon monoxide wouldn't be
my first choice if I was a ghost mostly
because when I think of terrifying ways
to die my first thought isn't how did
Peter Russo from house of cards die wait
wasn't she a ghost a minute ago wasn't
she born on the couch why is she in a
solid state now I'm glad I'm confused
kid who he's totally possessed and knows
his name is hunter and was 100% on board
with coming back to his old family
suddenly has second thoughts for reasons
you might as well spend the wheel of
fish to find I guess because the one
time she tried to show her dad that
one-millisecond flash-- and he didn't
think it was real she decided that the
small simple size was enough never to
show her parents even more compelling
evidence later Katie always maximizes
the amount of time for the cameras just
before she steals children / kills fools
another thing Falls is now the time to
throw mom across the room why not
earlier and didn't we hear these demons
feed off your fear she's the one that
believes in demons the least in this
family
Katie decided to take the moms body out
the front door when removing evidence
that's the best option in my opinion I'm
some crazy online about that triangle
symbol in this like coven you mean we
discovered more than you already figured
out earlier when you and Alex read about
it on the Internet
you did not in this like coven we have
ten minutes left in the movie and we're
just begin to explain some of what's
going on but not really we all know that
Katie is portrayed in the first two
films can't move fast without making
loud stomping noises but yet here we are
a minute ago Katie the spoons to the
moms body outside somewhere probably in
the aluminum recycling bin or something
now she's like okay I'm Michael Myers
now can anyone in the audience tell me
why the demon keeps dragging people on
the floor become disinterested and stops
I'm assuming to go to work on his
Walking Dead podcast we now enter the
why is this person running with a camera
portion of the story especially after
being dragged on the floor by a ghost
and she knows the people across the
street are evil of all the bizarre
camera moments in this series this one
might make sense the least and if you
tell me she needs the cameras night
vision to see then that opens up even
more bull we don't have time for why is
this moment any different than any other
moment to start killing everyone why did
they just beat up the girl and kill them
off it seems like they just decided to
make a movie but forgot to write
anything there are plenty of things for
dad to grab onto yet he is just slightly
flailing his arms as if he doesn't want
to live I know this is a Spanish
newspaper and the headline is covered up
slightly but all I can think of is anal
cuz this kid doing out here right now is
this the kid storage there's a 15 year
old girl in our yard send
it's your aunt Katie
I have to be rescued it can you come
save me you've lost you just don't know
it
I've lost look at the board I have take
the draw or the championship soldier
never leaves a man behind you know she's
not my girlfriend I find her interesting
because she's a client and because she
sleeps above her covers 4 feet above her
covers
I was saying rulers